[Applause]
hi everyone so and this is something
seriously wrong with you you'll probably
notice I'm not uh jinny
Bryan unfortunately jinny tested
positive for covid and I volunteered to
do slide karaoke for her so I have never
seen these slides
before uh I am however familiar with the
topic so we should we go and I will say
that uh Jenny developed these slides
knowing that I will be delivering them
live with no preparation so there may be
some surprises along the
way and hopefully this will take me
about 20 minutes but we'll see okay so
the point of this talk really is to
announce that there's a new version a
new edition of the r packages book uh I
wrote the first edition Jenny
contributed most of the second edition
uh really I think updating it for the
the the things that the things the ways
that our our package development
workflow is changed and also to
introduce some new like this new whole
game chapter that Jenny wrote which
really introduces you to the whole flow
of developing a package which we really
strongly believe that with like Dev
tools and use this and roxygen and test
that is like really really easy these
days like if it takes you longer than
like 60 seconds to create a package
something is wrong with your workflow
now obviously uh you know that's not
going to be much of a package in 60
seconds but it's get going to get you
started and onto more
things so in this
slide uh you will see I think you know
there yeah so we work so the the the
first addition of our package is like
really you can see kicked off in like
2015 and nothing really happened for
like 5 years BAS basically with this
book it just sat it was you know live
people were using it but it wasn't being
updated even as the practices that we
and the Tidy verse team were
using so a couple of years ago I was
like we probably should really update
this and hey Jenny you know you do lots
of package development uh wouldn't you
love to write a book and Jenny because
she had never written a book before said
yes I would love to do that
uh I think she has some level of regret
about that but overall I think we're
very very happy uh with the second
edition and I believe that jinny will
not be writing any other books in the
future okay oh
W so Jenny has
uh really been pushing the limits of
keynote uh
recently but the the the second edition
really is you know it's a lot bigger I
think so we've doubled the number of
pages we've doubled the number of
authors and we've done something to the
number of chapters which is very hard to
see due to this extremely deceptive 3D
Bart I will tell you one really cool
thing about 3D bar charts and that is uh
if you want to know like the first time
or the first time I know of that someone
like railed about how bad 3D bar out to
her there's this really cool paper from
like the
1940s saying like don't use 3D bar
charts and that just blows my mind
because it wasn't just like pick a
sitting in keynote it's like go away and
draw three like who wants to draw 3D
Barts by
hand so what's changed in the last eight
years
[Applause]
Jenny has really outdone himself with
the
[Applause]
graphics uh these were not produced with
ggplot 2 I should
add you have to pick up the pace oh I
have to pick up the pace okay okay so
really 2015 three main packages since
then the number of packages has really
exploded as uh I think I forget what we
we the conscious uncoupling of div tools
into smaller packages uh again you know
you only need to get us this or Dev
tools that gives you all these tools but
behind the scenes a much much richer um
thing so if there's only one thing you
take away from this talk it's that the I
think the easiest highest impact thing
you can do for a package is to give it a
website and you can do that in one
minute like you can get a decent website
for your package in under a minute you
can certainly spend much more time on it
to make it awesome but massive payout
just for that one line of
code so uh Davis was joking earlier that
Jenny was just going to have a a slide
that said live demo but she did make a
video and so here is a video uh
showing uh a little bit of the package
development
workflow uh we've got vignettes we've
got our
files uh We've we don't seem to have any
tests in here uh but this is a pretty
simple package right with just one
function and one vignette and it's going
to be pretty easy to turn this into a
website we've already passed arandic
that's you know really good uh good good
practice to be doing uh it's well formed
and uh I think we're really ready to do
something fun on the next line fun and
amazing and that is is we're going to
call use package down now that's going
to create some basic metadata not much
excitement going on here with this
metadata uh but we can also do that with
an addin if we want uh and that addin is
going to build the package it's going to
take the contents of the package combine
it with that metadata and it's going to
make a bunch of HTML files for us and
that gives us this basic website we've
got a reference page every we've got a
reference index every function gets its
own web page all the examples get run
they get hyperlink they get nicely synx
highlighted similarly for the vignettes
they get built in a way that you can
really really easily share for others
everything is cross link and Hy and uh
footnotes get turned into nice popups
and you can click on things and things
happen now if you use uh GitHub uh if
your packages on in the open there's
even better you can call use package
down get her Pages what this is going to
do is automate the whole process of
building that website it's going to call
uh package down build site for you every
single time your site changes and it's
going to publish it to GitHub pages so
this is seriously like a one minute
workflow to get your website up on the
internet where you can share it with
others GitHub this uses GitHub actions
uh which is a really great tool that
that ensures your code doesn't just work
in the one place where you wrote it but
also works on some other random computer
on the internet and the chances are if
it works in two places it's going to
work in just about any places uh a bunch
of actions are kind of built in check
standard uh it's going to run our
Command check and combine all of these
cool packages that you have locally with
the power of get
up what else is new in the our packages
second edition uh lots of expanded
coverage on the work work flows like
what is it that we actually do uh lots
more diagrams and updated
diagrams uh one of I think one of the
things that's really changed in the last
five years for us uh are practices
around testing things like code coverage
uh how ideas about how to organize our
tests these are now written up uh in our
packages in a way that is hopefully easy
for you to read and understand and learn
about we've also learned a lot more
about how you look after the package and
the longterm how you manage the process
of releases how you deal with cran and
the way that is uh is helpful for you
and it's helpful for them as
possible so I think this is my favorite
new chapter this is all 100% Jenny work
uh this is the whole game this is really
showing you like if you've never made a
package before if you've got no idea why
you'd want to make a package here's how
you can go from that function you have
in a random R file and get it into a
form that's easy for you to share with
others it's that's easy that's
documented that's tested that's in git
and then is hopefully being checked
automatically by GitHub
actions so building on top of that like
a lot of the time you're not going to
start from a c completely clear slate
you are going to start uh by trying to
get the get the package that exists
inside of your code currently out into
the world and so really focusing on like
what's the difference between writing
code and a script that what you do all
the time as a data scientist how is it
going to change when you how do you need
to think about code differently as you
move to create a package instead of a
script lots more information about how a
package is
structured uh more information about the
various ways your package transitions
from various different states you know
how does your you're very used to using
install. packages to get a package from
cran onto your computer you you're
familiar with using library to get a
package it's installed on your computer
into memory on current ah all of those
things change a little bit when you
start developing your own package
because now you're going to have the
source version of a package on your
computer you're not installing it from
cray you are building it from scratch
and your life uh there's certainly ways
to do this without Dev tools uh they are
painful and horrible uh in my biased
opinion and div tools was really
designed to make those problems go away
I still remember like the first time I
taught package development was like a
two-day workshop I turned up and I was
like okay now go to the terminal and
type R command build and people were
like what's a terminal and I was like
huh people aren't actually born knowing
what a terminal is and how to use it and
so rather than trying to teach the whole
world how to use a terminal we've
invested a lot into this the dev tool
the goal of Dev tools is that you can
stay in R you don't need to switch out
to use a terminal if you don't want
to other big workflow difference between
uh packages from cran and your own
package you're going to use Dev Tools
load all a lot this is kind of a
simulation of the package building and
load loading process it's a simulation
because it's designed to be as fast as
possible it's not 100% accurate but it
allows you to build this like iterative
Loop where you try something out in the
car load it and then you can experience
it in the
console I think this is one of the the
diagrams uh that I like the best
although as I look at it now it looks
kind of vaguely sexual
um but really like the these are the the
four the four functions the four
keyboard shortcuts command shift L
command shift T command shift d and
comun of e that this is your life as a
package developer you write some code
you edit some code you you load it you
run it once you've done some interactive
experimentation with it you write some
tests you check those tests work uh you
write some documentation you look at
that documentation everything in Dev
tools and the surrounding packages is
designed around this idea of like tight
feedback loops you might not know
exactly what you're trying to do but you
can try it out see what happens and
iterate if you want to learn more uh I
have no I assume we're nearing the end
of the talk
uh if you want to learn more uh you can
the best place to start is Dev tools.
ar.org we've got some great cheat sheets
there that were newly updated I think
they are hopefully included in the cheat
sheets you got in the conference and
newly updated all the latest advice on
our workflow and uh we're not finished
so now we're going to talk more about
testing how much got like seven minutes
okay okay we've got quite a lot of
time so again like one of the things as
I said earlier like one of the I think
things that we have learned as like we
the Tidy verse team have become more
experienced package developers
developers is just the importance of
testing and one of the things one of the
reasons that we've kind of exposed
ourselves more to test in the wild is
now one of our policies is is that if we
make a breaking change in a tidy verse
package a change that breaks causes
packages on cran and no longer pass our
Command check we are going to give you a
pull request to fix that problem and
what that means is we are now like
parachuting in to some random package on
cray that has some random failing test
and trying to fix
it and like this is challenging for me
because I like to make things like clean
and perfect from the ground up and I
want to like rewrite everything but I'm
just going to put my blinkers on and be
like here's one tiny problem let's fix
it but this has like forced us to see
like what are the problems that people
are actually having in real life and
that like one of those problems we see
is like how do you manage State and test
like sometimes you need to sometimes
your functions depend on things that are
happening in the world outside of your
function argument uh if you're modifying
options then if you do this the wrong
way this is going to affect like every
other test that happens after
this so we've been to build out the with
our package which is going to let you
just temporarily make those changes the
changes are going to be scoped to the
current function as soon as that
function is over the changes will
revert the other big challenge is like
code that lives outside of tests so if
your fuy 2 does that test fails and now
you want to create a minimal repr you're
waiting through like lines and based on
our experience of cramp packages tens
hundreds or possibly thousands of lines
of code in this file trying to figure
out exactly what does this test depend
on so tests unlike functions it's okay
to have a little duplication in your
test it's not so bad to copy and paste
in your test because you are not like
that they're they're generally less less
coupled like if you change one test you
don't have to worry about updating every
single other test it's okay to do more
copying and pasting so your tests are
easier to understand in isolation and if
there are problems that easier to fix
and it's always better to do this kind
of like up front rather than when you're
trying to debug like this failing test
which is causing your package to fail I
comeand check on cran you've got an
angry email and you need to like fix
this and you're cranky uh it's so much
more pleasant if you're prepared for
like Angry you in the future with these
very simple uh tests rather than trying
to have to do them on the
Fly we've also continued to to revise or
advice on like where do you put stuff
that can't live just in the in the test
if you're duplicating code in your test
and you want to remove that where do you
put it uh helpers uh run by uh both load
o and test or they're available
interactively so when you're
interactively uh interacting with your
tests uh they're available to you then
not just when they're test
running go faster okay go faster so uh
we also have just continued to learn
more about how do you how do packages uh
survive in the wild for a long amount of
time I've been kind of joking that like
gigot 2 is about to turn 18 so it's time
to emancipate it and it's just going to
be responsible for its own maintenance
in the
future but as many of you probably
experiened in tidy ver packages already
we're moving to this explicit
acknowledgement that there's some life
cycle behind functions functions will
stay in the stable uh phase of the life
cycle for a long time but sometimes we
need to get rid of them and we don't
want to get rid of them quickly so
everyone has a chance to accommodate so
now we're moving through this process of
of
deprecation we're also huge Believers of
checkl checklists in the tidyverse so
whenever we release packages we call
this function called use _ relase issue
that creates this beautiful checklist
where all you have to do
is uh work down this list uh you guys
are really not cheering as much as the
other room
so that's that's a you problem not a me
problem uh
and the the the entire package
development ecosystem is no longer just
a product of of the Tidy verse team so I
you know really want to appreciate
everyone who has contributed to the
books to the packages whether that's
with code or issues or ideas or feedback
like this is a community effort we'd
love uh the help we get from others uh
and here is a photo of me and Jenny in
Iceland
and it is very cold and Iceland compared
to where I am used to but not where
Jenny is used to we went to a a really
there's a really cool uh place in
Iceland called and I'm blanking on the
name the sky Lagoon in the sky Lagoon
there's like this kind of like it's a a
hot springs thing there's like a
Vancouver room which is where Jenny's
from it's like cold and raining Jenny
loved that room and I hated it and
there's also like the Houston room which
is like the SAA where is extremely hot
and and humid and I loved it and Jenny
hated
it so again if you want to learn more
our packages is the place to be and that
is it thank
[Applause]
you